[Music]
in shitty plain news plane oh no
airplane that's uh would wish Allegiant
United Legion spirit but those are like
United might be a level up elite for
sure Allegiant is horrible illusion I
mean yeah yeah Allegiant thing they're
like discount airlines there you can
it's fine why would you inclined line
recline is a right one so blind
sometimes rewind thank you thank you
submitted by Gabriel from Santa Clarita
Delta has apologized after a man had to
sit in dog poo for the duration of his
flight did he know he was sitting in the
Dukes oh he knew but that felt good and
they knew yeah they'll get a new [ __ ]
out of the three eggs like like on the
same level its United American and Delta
out of those three I like Delta the most
yeah I got the TVs I be talking [ __ ]
about Delta by still you yeah me too I
have all three cuz American they got
smaller you noticed that
mmm-hmm this chairs just yeah I think
they put more [ __ ] and they squeezed it
up it feels way more cramped androgen
was a Virgin America and JetBlue are
dope but they don't go along yeah
yeah well Virgin America fell bought out
by Alaska mm-hmm well I'll be expanding
out now well I've never ridden Alaska
they they just took over all the virgins
claim oh really
yeah so it's funny cuz like the whole
plane still looks pink or purple or
whatever but then it has like a last
garlic oh what the [ __ ]
yeah oh that's so sad yeah so um this
Delta Airlines passenger he was flying
from Atlanta to Miami and so when he
approached his seat he sat down and he
accidentally got some dog [ __ ] on him
and he realized like it smells like [ __ ]
and then he started looking there was
like [ __ ] on the wall [ __ ] on the seat
[ __ ] everywhere he didn't [ __ ] look
before he sat down I know I always I
always look dude I just said the flight
attendant didn't yeah I come in and
cleaning and he couldn't smell that I
could saw hmm I know I would have
smelled it before I saw it yeah well he
well he stepped in it I don't know if he
got it on his ass or anything but he
took photos of his shoe his shitty shoe
oh my god that's a huge [ __ ] nugget he
looks nice too
yes if you think what I like the
Platinum Flyers middle any like whatever
like millennial where's the Millennium
Falcon's millennium wait so he was in
first class
Oh million miler this what else I can't
retain him rhenium Falcon is what she
was kids
he's a Millennium Falcon firefighter
that's what diamond medallion and a
million miler oh I could see why I
thought [ __ ] [ __ ] he's like part
of that class he should be the fly
[ __ ] yeah so then as soon as he
notice that there was [ __ ] there like he
told the flight attendants these simple
words I can't retainer and then so they
were just like oh well that's not our
responsibility somebody from the gate
needs to take care of that we're in the
middle of an active boarding we're busy
if you want you can get off the plane
and talk to somebody what
like yeah yeah that's crazy he was like
well what the [ __ ] like I'm not gonna
miss my flight like I have to get off
like D board the plane and then find
someone to come and clean up my seat
like that so job that is their job I've
never heard that before if there was
vomit or anything like that they would
[ __ ] take care of that well that's
the thing that's crazy was saying that
when you spoke to a manager that she
said if the cleaning crew didn't do
their job that's not my problem
you even asked him like what's your
problem right Wow
so then a bunch of incompetent [ __ ] I
would I bet you this is [ __ ] the
Detroit kind uh this is probably like
the Detroit team Delta yeah yeah so then
um so then what the ended up doing is
they gave him a towel and some Bombay
like gin like alcohol I drink it off no
drugs no I need you bring yourself
anyone smell anything
yeah that's what they so he ended up
cleaning as best as he could do they
didn't want to missus why he was like he
even told himself he's like oh I try to
keep my composure cuz I don't want to be
one of those people you see on the news
I get kicked off the flight damn what a
nice guy yeah so he's just like put up
with it and when he landed that's when
he posted about it and then that's when
finally Delta Airlines a spokesperson
and apologized so sad that's the only
way to get tend to [ __ ] your friend
listen [ __ ] dude I will [ __ ] get all
the names of people involved I would
take pictures I would make video like
damn dude I would make sure those people
lost their jobs yeah so then the the
reason why he was sitting in [ __ ] was
because it's it there was a sick service
dog that was just [ __ ] all over the
place that's why they didn't clean it up
and so Delta they apologized and then
they were untrained service dog with
that piece someone just bought the
service dog [ __ ] bastard yeah those
[ __ ] horrible yeah
[Laughter]
there's websites that you could just go
and just they don't even validate it a
lot of people that do it as long as your
dog is trained it's okay
our dogs are not yeah that's what I mean
but you're not gonna you know that but
you don't fly with them I don't put the
best on the wheel do not put the vest on
meatloaf do bite other people in each
other yeah so they ended up offering him
50,000 miles in conversation and then
they also that's nothing did the flight
no you need me to give me like a million
miles but I want a new 50,000 miles like
England's dance like this is a health
code violation yeah it is they were made
aware of the feces before the flight
even took off yeah and I'm sure they
just [ __ ] sue them the dog [ __ ] in
the middle of the flight I get it I get
it but it's still up to the [ __ ]
employees to clean it yeah that just
comes with the job like what if a
toddler took a [ __ ] in the middle of the
plane yeah and the mom has like five
kids and she can't get to it you know
like there's just I don't know that's
just making it some of them because in
this situation they could have avoided a
lawsuit if they compensated him
correctly you know I mean it's night Hey
apologies
it's your flight whatever you'll get
life free whatever flights for the rest
of the year dah dah dah dah dah dah but
because they did that slap in the face
and now he's gonna sue them for a
shit-ton worm oh yeah he's planning on
saying you know what let's get 150
thousand miles and yeah I think that'll
be great he'll be happy that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] fifty thousand miles yeah it's
like he's like he mentioned like you
know he's a diamond medallion and a
50,000 I got 50,000 miles is like less
than $500 in value yeah that's what he
was saying like if this is how they
treat their top tier like how do they
treat people that aren't even part like
[ __ ] on a so upsetting dude I'd be so
[ __ ] mad I get priority boarding can
we hang out with you yeah your card is
better than mine
okay then I guess we can't hang you you
guys probably get I get I get group 1
priority boarding or something you know
I get priority that's a head of group on
but you guys probably get like platinum
boarding with us yeah oh you guys get in
first
I don't know what he's talking about I'm
gonna go again if you have the American
Express cause you have to book the trip
did you book the trip with your car AMEC
throw the inner fear you didn't go you
went on the Expedia and American Express
Travel thing is my point usually hooks
it up oh maybe it's the Delta specific
you have to get the Delta platinum cuz I
mean I'm Delta gold right so like I
guess a pre-check
meet you I think we all are like we
booked our Vegas hotel with through the
interface and then we got what was like
hundred dollars with the massage
teleworks the guess another great cuz I
I just booked a recent one too and
nothing happened no we're a group six oh
yeah but did you guys fly Delta though
now see that's what yeah yeah pick and
choose what I hear okay and that's the
pick so at the beginning of the year you
get an email and then they go which one
do you want to do a partner with and it
could be United American or Delta and if
what depending on which one you pick
they give you perks for that airline and
you're stuck with that airline for a
whole year until the next year they send
you another one you know what cuz I
booked a flight so I picked Delta and
then I booked a delta flight but then
they're saying that you know that $200
credit that they give you it's only for
a baggage fees
we didn't we don't check our bags
because we do carry on or what does it
call Global Entry you use it for Global
Entry stuff so we already have you guys
really thought of it I still I still
like Delta and I haven't had any
problems in a long time yeah that's
shitty management it's so shitty
management shitty management I feel like
all American Airlines are just shitty
though compared to any other Asian ones
Wow
do you guys know what's going on even
know what Korean air family yeah your
service is amazing but that family is so
[ __ ] up what what the people who the
family that owns Korean air like every
single person is like getting arrested
for water
what's one family yeah like the [ __ ]
wife of the CEO she beat an employee on
camera like the employee ran away and
she started chasing her that's a service
good because that's all they really care
they're beating them for the customer
yeah reason why it's so good I mean
anything that's efficient and good like
Amazon they [ __ ] up their you know you
know like you got it
can't win yeah what do you want do you
want a company that's good towards the
customer or a company that's good
towards it o-o County boys are good to
their to their employees and to their
customer out west
yeah they're not that they're still not
even Asian airlines like Asian airlines
like if I see full snoring and their
blanket falls off they get on their
knees and they go back in code yeah
there's so much care but you know why
though for them getting a job in the
airline industry is like top-notch
plastic surgeon [ __ ] but for us it's you
know it's not like they're not our
service like flight attendants they're
not valued as high as as people in Asia
you know it's like girls that my
sister's friend was a flight attendant
you try to be a Korean Air flight
attendant so that you can move up to
being a flight attendant in first-class
and find your husband that's why most
pilots didn't quit or the chose
retirement yes
I'm big do you think about the army you
got to be able to read fine attendant
and the bottom so like you gotta stand
I'm certain height and then you gotta
like reach a marker and then your hand
has to reach like a certain my mom
couldn't do that that she's too short
yeah sure I'm gonna help people that's
why most flat ends on Asian airlines are
actually pretty tall yeah but like the
American Airlines ones they're not
[Music]
[Music]